Hola Esto es África siete días el
magazine donde les presentamos la
actualidad del continente africano Mi
nombre es amal benotman Y estos son los
titulares Francia tiene un mes para
retirar sus fuerzas de burkina faso una
petición formalmente formulada por el
portavoz del gobierno burginés hace 50
años Amílcar Cabral fue asesinado
apodado el Lenin africano es hoy una
referencia en el Continente en esta
emisión descontamos la historia del
líder de las independencias africanas en
Barcelona España se celebró la sexta
edición del festival África moment una
iniciativa para establecer vínculos
entre la diáspora africana y el público
español a través de las Artes escénicas
comenzamos en burkina faso donde la
junta militar en el poder pidió La
retirada de las tropas francesas de la
capital guagadugo escuchemos al portavoz
del gobierno burkinés
lo que denunciamos hoy es el acuerdo que
permite la presencia de las fuerzas
francesas en burkina faso
pero más allá de eso no es el fin de las
relaciones diplomáticas entre burkina
faso y Francia de la franja
las fuerzas francesas tienen su base en
petición de urquina faso y sus
autoridades
y por supuesto también corresponde a las
autoridades burkinesas pedir su retirada
y denunciar el acuerdo militar que
permite a estas fuerzas estar en guaga
pero París quiere que el jefe de la
junta Ibrahim traoré confirme la
petición de retirar a las tropas antes
de tomarla en cuenta varias fuentes
reportan desacuerdos en el del gobierno
burkines sobre la decisión de mantener o
no a los militares franceses
las relaciones entre Francia y burkina
faso se han deteriorado
considerablemente en los últimos meses
una sucesión de fricciones que
analizamos en el siguiente informe
el sentimiento ha ido en aumento en los
últimos meses en burkina faso donde la
población estuvo exigiendo el fin de la
cooperación militar con París y la
salida de las tropas especiales que se
encuentran en el país desde 2011
un país independiente
hemos decidido que queremos librar la
guerra contra el terrorismo con buenos
socios
creemos que Francia no es el socio ideal
para acompañarnos hasta la victoria
final
la misma actitud se reproduce en el más
alto nivel político inmediatamente
después de tomar el poder El capitán
golpista Ibrahim traoré se fijó como
objetivo reconquistar el territorio
ocupado por los terroristas en este
contexto inició un acercamiento a Moscú
y se distanció de Francia siguiendo así
El ejemplo del vecino Mali
la cooperación militar entre Francia y
burkina faso está sujeta a un acuerdo
que prevé el apoyo y respaldo a las
fuerzas burkinesas si lo necesitan pero
a pesar del aumento de los atentados
yihadistas esta cooperación se encuentra
estancada desde hace meses
la interrupción del acuerdo es el último
episodio de una sucesión de rupturas de
burkina faso con Francia en diciembre
las autoridades suspendieron la emisora
de radio francesa rfi acusándola de
haber transmitido mensajes
intimidatorios de un dirigente
chihadista lo que la radio negó
paralelamente varias ongs financiadas
por Francia fueron expulsadas y
ciudadanos franceses acusados de
espionaje en enero las autoridades
burkinesas exigieron la salida del
embajador francés lukalat por su parte
París intentó calmar la situación y
envió a su secretaria de estado para
reestablecer cierta normalidad pero esta
visita no cambió nada
de Su futuro cada vez más lejos de la
antigua potencia colonial
hace 50 años Amílcar Cabral líder
revolucionario de Guinea bizao y cabo
verde fue asesinado por los servicios de
inteligencia portugueses Cabral Era uno
de los pensadores y activistas más
famosos y respetados de las
independencias africanas
nosotros no hacemos una conexión entre
el color de la piel y la capacidad de
explotar a las personas la independencia
como doctrina Más allá de la lucha
Amílcar Cabral fue político agrónomo
escritor pero pasó a la historia como
líder independentista nació en Guinea
avisó estudió en Lisboa donde se
licenció en agronomía a principios de
los años 50 regresó a su país más tarde
fundó el Partido africano para la
independencia de Guinea y las islas de
cabo verde Cabral desarrolló entonces su
visión política
anticolonialista de marxista pero
adaptada a las condiciones africanas
la lepanas independencia para qué
África para nosotros en primer lugar
para ser nosotros mismos ser hombres
africanos con todo lo que nos
caracteriza pero en marcha hacia una
vida mejor e identificarnos cada vez más
con los demás hombres del mundo al mundo
la vía pacífica fue un fracaso Cabral y
su partido pasaron a la lucha armada
conquistaron gran parte del territorio
guineano a pesar de las brutales
acciones portuguesas bombas de napal y
fósforo blanco educación agronomía
alfabetización formación de campesinos y
obreros el líder revolucionario tenía
una visión global de su lucha política
pero Cabral no vio los frutos de la
lucha de toda una vida fue asesinado el
20 de enero de 1973 por miembros del ala
militar de su partido a las órdenes de
la potencia colonial portuguesa
aproximadamente un año después de su
muerte cabo verde y tiene aviso
obtuvieron su independencia consecución
de 20 años de lucha
cambiamos de tema en davos Suiza
Finalizó el foro económico mundial la
guerra en Ucrania y la crisis de la
pandemia de Kobe 19 fueron los temas más
debatidos muestra en guiada especial
Daniela Blandón se reunió con la
activista feminista senegalesa vineta
diopp que se mostró optimista sobre la
capacidad de hacer frente a la próxima
pandemia
hemos estado debatiendo para asegurarnos
que tendremos soluciones concretas
planes concretos y también medidas para
enfrentar a las próximas crisis
no se trata solo de prometer sino de
aplicar medidas recopilar datos aprender
de ellos de compartir experiencias de
distintos niveles y garantizar que se
puedan aplicar algunas de estas
soluciones
Así que creo que preparar prevenir es
mejor que curar y por eso estamos aquí
en davos
en Barcelona España se celebró en
diciembre la sexta edición del festival
África moment un encuentro internacional
de artes vivas que busca enlazar la
diáspora africana con el público español
a través de espectáculos pero también
con capacitaciones y cursos para
artistas profesionales el siguiente es
un informe de nuestra corresponsal
elisengel
es bailarín profesional nacido en Costa
de Marfil
vive actualmente en Barcelona donde hoy
imparte una formación de bailes
africanos en el marco del festival
África moments
estamos ahí luchando vea el potencial
que tiene este baile la fuerza que tiene
la fuerza de expresión y para contar
también nuestra historia lo que somos
dirigido a artistas profesionales de
todas las disciplinas este curso Busca
romper con los prejuicios y la mirada
eurocéntrica
sigue habiendo un exoticismo a los
africano no quitar ya está porque tiene
tanta belleza y tanta y se limita una
mirada Si lo vemos como Carlos como algo
exótico
una formación de 10 días que pone el
foco en la relación cuerpo voz con la
ayuda de profesores que representan la
diversidad del continente
la idea también es de transmitir la
buena información
correctamente entonces Claro que igual
uno piensa algo antes de llegar aquí y
luego se va con otra idea Así que eso
también es importante no eso lo
divertirse también
África y Europa es el propósito del
festival que también ayuda a los
artistas a través de una residencia Ana
María bailarina brasileña y senegales
fueron acogidos dos semanas para crear
su nuevo proyecto
el festival sobre todo nos aporta la
oportunidad de hacerlo concreto porque
cuando uno uno puede tener muchas ideas
y pero si no tiene apoyo de la
producción nada se puede hacer una
oportunidad para intercambiar también
opiniones entre profesionales
en dos semanas ya hemos enseñado dos
veces la obra internamente para tener
opiniones y eso es la residencia
aprender de sus comentarios
frente a un público cada vez más
numeroso la sexta edición del festival
concluyó con la representación de las
compañías residentes y con la intención
de traer una diversidad real en el
escenario europeo
[Aplausos]
y para cerrar esta edición vamos a
atacar la capital senegal es acogió los
all Africam music owards que premian a
los mejores talentos del continente
entre los ganadores el maliense ibagué
se llevó el premio a mejor compositor y
la estrella nigeriana de lafrobits fue
elegido mejor artista les dejamos con
estas imágenes Gracias por su sintonía
la actualidad sigue en France 24 y
France 24.com
[Música]